[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and meet those coming up with the
solutions this show aims to take you to
the heart of the climate crisis
explain the data driving the changes
that are already affecting us
but also show you just how far we've
come
and today we're looking at the numbers
around bitcoin because a new
initiative's been
launched to try to make the
cryptocurrency industry 100
renewable in a moment we'll look at just
how much energy
digital currencies use but first what is
bitcoin
it's a form of electronic money that no
bank or government controls
bitcoins are essentially computer files
stored in a digital
wallet app on a smartphone or computer
it's based on blockchain a database that
stores every transaction ever made
and it's possible to buy bitcoins or
they can be created using a computer
in a process known as mining and it's
that last process that can use a huge
amount of energy with powerful computers
programmed
to try to generate them the global
electricity consumption of bitcoin is
now
greater than the total amount of
electricity consumed in argentina
sweden and the netherlands and china is
the center
for bitcoin mining responsible for more
than 65
of activity every month so
what does this look like our asia
correspondent tom cheshire has got
exclusive access
to a bitcoin farm
[Applause]
we can't tell you where exactly in
western china this
is what we're about to see is being kept
secret from the authorities
welcome to my mind involved wow
this might be crazy bitcoin is a digital
currency
but this is where the very real process
of mining it
happens thousands of computers solving
mathematical problems
and earning bitcoins as a result around
80 000 pounds worth
each day but this is a grey area in
china and so this mining farm is hidden
inside an industrial site the government
in china they don't they shut down some
like
mining farms in mongolia already
but we don't know what's uh what's their
next move so it's better to you know
keep it low does the government know
about this farm
no not right now bitcoin mining requires
a huge
amount of energy that's why authorities
in the province of inner mongolia have
banned operations like this
to meet energy consumption targets but
the price of bitcoin keeps soaring and
investors
keep rushing in the founder of this
company started his first mining farm in
iran
but says that china is safer the entire
site was built in just two months
everyone working on it can be trusted
and because it uses an existing
industrial power supply its electricity
consumption shouldn't raise any
suspicion
we're in a bitcoin boom and this is the
frontier it is dirty
it is noisy it uses a lot of energy and
there are hundreds of grey sites like
this all across
china beyond the reach of the
authorities the question is what effect
that could have
on the environment there are greener
ways to mine
this is a huge bitcoin farm in sichuan
south west china
the region has lots of hydropower so
the electricity is green but also more
importantly
cheap bitcoin is is kind of relentless
in its drive for
efficiency in energy production energy
consumes
majority of the cost of mining bitcoin
so miners will always find the areas
around the world which have
low cost and sustainable supply of
energy the energy here
is low cost but it isn't green and as
long as china keeps building coal power
plants
bitcoin miners will take advantage a
sustainable future for bitcoin
isn't here yet tom cheshire sky news
west china
and you can find out if tom can describe
what bitcoin is in 10 seconds
by watching the weekly climate show on
sky news social channels our app
and our website let's take a look now at
some of the day's other climate news
and britain could get the world's first
large power station that burns hydrogen
energy companies sse thermal and equinor
want to build two plants near scumthorp
that will make enough low carbon energy
to supply a million homes one plant will
use
carbon capture technology and the other
will be powered by
green hydrogen green hydrogen
is made out of splitting water it
requires a lot of energy and that
energy needs to be from renewable
sources
so green sources if you like like solar
and wind
the byproduct of this is only oxygen
so no co2 handling required
[Applause]
bangladesh is one of the countries most
vulnerable to climate change
but it's also one of the biggest
producers of methane
new satellite images show the 12 highest
methane emission rates this year have
occurred over the country
the highlighted areas you can see here
are plumes of the greenhouse gas which
is up to 84 times
more potent than carbon dioxide
scientists have captured rare footage of
what they believe is the world's
largest sea grass meadow in the indian
ocean
underwater gardens like the saya de maya
bank play a vital role in tackling
climate change
as they absorb huge amounts of carbon
dioxide from their surroundings
and calling all beach lovers surfers
against sewage
urging people to take part in a mass
cleanup of britain's seasides
the charity wants to clear litter from a
million miles of coastline by the end of
the year
to tackle plastic pollution
[Applause]
and in the first episode of our weekly
podcast climate cast dr freddie otto
tells me how she thinks
we should be changing the narrative
around climate change
that's out tomorrow and you can find it
wherever you normally get your podcast
from
now in november world leaders will be in
glasgow for the cop 26 climate summit
they're meant to set out how much they
can reduce their nation's emissions by
and when japan the world's fifth biggest
emitter of greenhouse gases has already
set a goal of being carbon neutral by
2050 and now it wants to make its 2030
target
more ambitious so japan has already
committed to cutting emissions by
26 from 2013 levels
by 2030 but they're now looking at
whether they can increase that
to 45 now the eu has raised its target
to cut emissions to
55 from 1990 levels
that's up from 40 and the uk has
announced plans for a 68
reduction in emissions by the end of the
decade compared to
1990 levels well joining me now is
our climate correspondent lisa holland
so lisa why are these countries
setting these targets now
well anna all countries who have signed
up to the paris agreement which was
signed back in
2015 have to come up with what's known
as an ndc which is a nationally
determined contribution
in other words it's by how much
countries say they'll reduce their
emissions so countries are coming up
with
interim targets for 2030. the uk led the
way last december saying that
it would reduce its emissions faster
than any other
major economy crucially we're waiting to
hear what the united states
promises to reduce its emissions by
others have already laid theirs out
countries like australia and brazil
which frankly have been condemned as
inadequate the fact of the matter is
though that
countries need to reduce their emissions
by 45
within the next 10 years if warming is
to be limited to 1.5 degrees above
pre-industrial
levels and currently the world is not on
that pathway
lisa thank you concentrations of carbon
dioxide in the atmosphere have hit their
highest
ever level the measurements from the
mauna loa observatory in hawaii show
global levels of co2
and now 50 above pre-industrial levels
last month atmospheric concentrations of
the greenhouse gas
averaged 417.14
parts per million well let's bring in dr
ella gilbert now who's a climate
scientist at the university of reading
and ella this is measured then in parts
per million so what does that mean and
why is that figure so high
yeah so parts per million is another way
of describing a ratio it's a bit like
percent except that
whereas percent means per 100 here we're
saying per million
and as you said concentrations reached a
record 417 parts per million which means
we're
halfway towards doubling our co2
emissions since before
human activity began and the reason it's
so high
is because human activity generates
greenhouse gas emissions
and that's especially from burning
fossil fuels and destroying natural
environments that remove
co2 from the atmosphere and ella i'm
going to take it over to the other side
of our studio to our data dashboard here
and take a look at this figure here
which is
total carbon dioxide emissions in the
atmosphere which is ticking up all the
time so
ella is that the same thing
it's related but it's not quite the same
so concentrations measure what's
currently
in the atmosphere whereas emissions tell
us how fast we're adding
to the concentration the atmosphere so
if
emissions are positive as you can see on
in your charts then we're adding to
atmospheric concentrations of greenhouse
gases
which contributes to global warming dr
ella gilbert thanks very much indeed
and you can see our data dashboard at
any time and read more about what those
numbers mean
on our website that's at skynews.com
climate
now in the latest from our climate
diaries series former postal worker ella
dash has been calling on companies
to remove plastic from their menstrual
products her petition to
end period plastic highlighted how the
waste is even more prevalent on european
beaches
than discarded plastic straws
[Applause]
i'm on a menstrual mission to eliminate
all plastic from period products
[Music]
my name's ella i'm an environmental
activist and founder of the end
period plastic campaign i was working a
regular day job
as a postal worker for royal mail while
i was out delivering letters and parcels
i began to notice the amount of waste
being thrown away each week was
increasing
you might be thinking why period
products what's so bad about them
that the fifth most common item found
polluting
europe's beaches they're more commonly
found
than straws or coffee cups tampons and
pads are made in their billions
are used for four to eight hours
disposed of
and can then take over 500 years to
break down
my campaign calls on manufacturers
and supermarkets to take responsibility
and bring about change by removing
plastic from their
period products the campaign is leading
to significant changes in the period
industry
three uk retailers removing plastic
tampon applicators
from their products saving over 17 tons
of plastic
each year coming up on the daily climate
show
tomorrow on the front line of the
climate crisis
in central america's dry corridor we've
got a special report from guatemala and
you can see that here at the same time
on sky news
see you then
[Music]